une vie typique au lycée est d'appartenir à
une nation mais je pensais avoir trouvé un
moyen d'obtenir la citoyenneté dans chaque nation
Gregg comment était ton été
été qu'est-ce que ce mot signifie même
plus certains au fil des ans j'ai surtout
traîné avec Earl il ressemble plus à un co  -travailleur
mais tu aimes les mêmes choses
JD est ton père je veux te
parler de quelque chose de triste ce qui
s'est passé bien vraiment Rachel a reçu un
diagnostic de leucémie
appelle-la juste je n'ai pas besoin de ton stupide [ __ ] en
fait le tien
ma mère est  me rendant socialement pire ouais
je sais laissez-moi juste passer du temps avec vous pendant
une journée que notre salut j'allais
pour un coup de
poing je ne peux pas te cogner d'ici
tu vois toi et Greg êtes des collègues
vous aimez la maison de campagne bien alors  si c'était
une histoire romantique touchante
et que tout à coup nous nous embrassions avec
le feu de mille soleils mais ce
n'est pas une histoire romantique touchante de toute façon je
réalise que la chose la plus importante que
vous puissiez faire est de faire un film pour le
bien de la région  ami
nm  ile et personne ne pourrait jamais